el hambre aumentó un 30% desde 2019 en
América Latina así lo reveló el más
reciente informe de la Organización de
las Naciones Unidas para la alimentación
y la agricultura FAO la pandemia del
covid-19 la crisis climática y la guerra
en Ucrania son las principales causas si
hablamos de números de América Latina y
el Caribe estamos hablando de 56
millones de personas que se encuentran
en situación de hambre más de 130
millones mínimamente que no se alimentan
bien son datos graves Haití es el
momento más dramático que existe en
América Latina y el Caribe a nivel
mundial el informe estima que más de 228
millones de personas padecen de hambre y
añadió a 22 países dentro de la
situación alimentaria más grave dentro
de los cuales se encuentran Haití
burkina faso y Mali estos lugares tienen
un alto número de personas que enfrentan
inseguridad alimentaria aguda crítica
junto con factores que empeoran y que se
esperan se intensifiquen aún más Durante
los próximos seis meses amenazando los
planes de la ONU como revela el presente
informe la inseguridad alimentaria se
deterioró todavía más en 2021 el único
Progreso realizado en relación con las
metas mundiales de nutrición para 2030
se registró en la lactancia materna
exclusiva en lactantes menores de seis
meses de edad y en el retraso del
crecimiento infantil
según la FAO la situación también se
verá afectada por la desaceleración de
las economías a nivel mundial en 2023 a
lo cual se le suman fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos así como la
esperada llegada del fenómeno del niño